[Music]
in this video you will learn how to use
cloud logging to determine what caused a
google compute engine instance to
unexpectedly reboot or shut down with a
few exceptions most activities related
to a virtual machine's life cycle are
automatically added to cloud logging in
the form of an audit log
audit logs are easiest way to gain
insights about vm's activities
when a vm reboots or shuts down
unexpectedly try doing the following
select the vm that shut down or rebooted
in this example the vm named my instance
shut down and rebooted unexpectedly
several times in the last 7 days
on the logs section of the vm details
page click cloud logging
cloud logging opens with a pre-built
query that filters for the instance id
narrow down your data set using
additional filters select the log name
drop down menu and look for cloud audit
category or search for audit
select the activity and system event
logs
activity logs describe changes made to
gcp resources such as compute instances
system event logs describe events
generated by google systems
narrow down the search to an approximate
time frame when the vm reboot or
termination occurred in this example we
know the shutdown occurred sometime in
the last 7 days
each cloud audit log entry displays a
compute instances label that describes
the method
associated with a particular instance
and which principle otherwise known as a
user or service account was associated
with that method
the following log entries are activities
audited operations that cannot be
executed instantly will run
asynchronously and therefore may appear
twice in the cloud login results
the first entry represents the request
itself and the second entry represents
the outcome of the request such as as a
success or an error message
for example this log entry illustrates
that on april 4th a stop instance method
was issued to my instance by the
principal user at example.com
then on april 7th a reset instance
method was issued to the same instance
by the service account scheduler bot at
example.com
the following log entries are system
events
system events will always show system at
google.com listed as the principal
because these events aren't driven by
direct user action
this log entry illustrates that on april
8th my instance was shut down by the
operating system
note that operating system reboots are
not tracked by the cloud audit logs
if the audit logs do not adequately
explain why an instance was rebooted
then it was most likely caused by an
operating system reboot in that case
consider investigating the operating
system logs for further clues
finally these two log entries logged on
april 9th indicate that the machine was
shut down due to a host error and was
automatically restarted
occasionally there might be problems
with the physical machine that hosts the
vm
this is referred to as a host error and
is indicated by the compute instances
host error method
which means that the vm was terminated
some examples of events that might cause
host errors are physical hardware
malfunctions or a natural disaster that
impacts the location of the google cloud
data center
after a host error the vm is set to
restart automatically which is indicated
by the compute instances automatic
restart method
to protect your applications and
services from these potentially
disruptive system events google has
shared several best practices that
explain how you can design robust
systems in google cloud use patterns for
scalable resilient apps encourages using
managed instance groups when appropriate
in addition compute engine also offers
live migration to keep your instances
running during a maintenance event
there are two methods which might appear
after a compute engine maintenance event
the compute instances migrate on host
maintenance method indicates that the
compute engine used a live migration to
keep your vm running during a
maintenance event
compute engine live migrates your
running instances to another host in the
same zone instead of requiring your vms
to be rebooted
this allows google to perform
maintenance that is integral to keeping
infrastructure protected and reliable
without interrupting any of your vms
live migrations are enabled by default
except for vms with gpus but this can be
disabled under the availability policy
of the particular instance
the compute instances terminate and host
maintenance method indicates that the
live migration was disabled or is not
supported on that particular vm so the
vm was terminated during the maintenance
event
for more information on how to
troubleshoot vm shutdowns or reboots and
a list of other common methods found in
cloud logging check out the official
troubleshooting documentation with the
link below in the description
thanks for watching
[Music]
you